The definition of
the Poisson process
gives us information
about the probability
that we get k arrivals during
an interval of length delta
when delta is a
very small number.
How can we find the
probability of k arrivals
during an interval of
some general length tau,
where tau is no
longer a small number?
In particular, we're interested
in the random variable denoted
N sub tau, which stands
for the number of arrivals
during an interval
of length tau.
And we wish to find the PMF
of this random variable,
the probability that N
sub tau is equal to k,
and which is what we
have been denoting
by this particular notation
in the context of the Poisson
process.
Now if, instead of
the Poisson model,
we had for the
Bernoulli process model,
we would know the answer.
S, the number of successes, or
number of arrivals in n slots,
has a PMF which is given
by the binomial formula.
Can we somehow use what we know
about the Bernoulli process
to find the answer for
the Poisson process?
The answer is yes, and it
involves a limiting argument
of the following kind.
We take the interval
from 0 to t and divide it
into a very large number of
intervals, so many of them,
where each one of the intervals
has a length of delta,
where delta is a small number.
And to push the analogy
with the Bernoulli process,
we will be calling those
little intervals as slots.
Now during each slot, we may
get zero arrivals, one arrival,
but there's also the
possibility that there
may be two arrivals, or
even more than two arrivals,
happening during
one of the slots.
Because of this, the
picture that we have here
is not quite the same as
for the Bernoulli process
because in the Bernoulli
process, each one of the slots
will get only 0 or 1.
So the source of the discrepancy
between the two models
is that here, a slot may
obtain two or more arrivals.
But how likely is this?
Let us look at the probability
that some slot, that
is, any one of the slots,
contains two or more arrivals.
That is, we're dealing with
the union of the events
that slot i has two
or more arrivals.
This event is the
union of these events
and, therefore, the probability
of this event is less than
or equal than the sum
of the probabilities
of the constituents events.
This is an inequality
that we have
seen at some point in the past.
And we're calling it
to the union bound.
Now what is this summation?
i ranges over the
different slots.
And we have tau
over delta slots,
so there's so many terms
that are being summed.
Now, during any particular
slot, the probability
of two or more arrivals is of
order delta squared, according
to the definition of
the Poisson process.
And this quantity
converges to 0 when
we let delta become
smaller and smaller.
So this means that the
discrepancy between the Poisson
and the Bernoulli model, which
was due to the possibility
that we might get two or
more arrivals during one
of those slots, this
discrepancy is something
that happens with
negligible probability.
In other words, the
probability that we
get k arrivals in
the Poisson model
is approximately the
same as the probability
that k slots have an arrival.
Since we're neglecting
the possibility
that some slot has
two or more arrivals,
this means that the number of
arrivals in the Poisson model
will be the same as the number
of slots that get an arrival.
This approximate equality
becomes more and more exact
as we let delta go to zero.
But now what is this quantity?
The probability that k
slots have an arrival
is something that
we can calculate
using the binomial
probabilities.
Each one of the slots
has a certain probability
of having an arrival.
And different slots are
independent of each other
by the defining properties
of the Poisson process.
Therefore, this approximation
that we have developed
satisfies the properties
of the Bernoulli process.
We have a certain probability
that each slot gets an arrival.
And we have independence
across slots.
This means that we can
use now the PMF that's
associated with
the Bernoulli model
to calculate this quantity
and then take the limit,
as delta goes to 0, to
obtain a formula for the PMF
for the Poisson process.
In more detail, what
we have is the number
of arrivals, which
is approximately
the same as the number of slots
that have an arrival, obeys
a binomial distribution
in the limit as delta
goes to 0-- a binomial
distribution in which
the probability of arrival
during each one of the slots
is approximately lambda
delta and the number of slots
goes to infinity.
And this happens in a way so
that the product of the two,
n times p, is equal
to-- this term times
this term gives us
a lambda times tau.
This term times
this term gives us
something that's order of delta.
So it's negligible.
So we have this
equality, and so this
is approximately lambda
tau with the approximation
becoming more and more exact
as we let delta go to zero.
So all we need to do is to take
the formula for the Bernoulli
process.
Use these values of p
and n and take the limit.
But this is a problem that
we have already encountered
and have analyzed.
If we let n go to
infinity, p goes to 0
so that their product
stays constant,
we have shown that the
binomial PMF converges
to the so-called Poisson
PMF that takes this form.
Notice one small
difference-- n times
p here is equal to lambda,
whereas here, n times
p is equal to lambda t.
This means that we need
to apply this formula,
but with lambda
replaced by lambda t,
and this gives us
the final answer.
This is the probability of k
arrivals during a time interval
of lenght t in the
Poisson process.
And this is a so-called Poisson
PMF with parameter lambda tau.
To summarize, our strategy
was to argue that the Poisson
process is increasingly
accurately described
by a Bernoulli process
if we discretize
time in a very fine
discretization.
And the approximation
becomes exact in the limit
when the discretization
is very fine.
So we took the corresponding
binomial formula
for the Bernoulli process
and took the limit
to that's associated
with the parameters
that we would obtain if we have
a very fine discretization.
And this gave us
the final formula.